Barack Obama has to find an excuse for
Hillary Clinton losing an ear guaranteed
presidential race and he has won it's
vlad Putin White House spokesman Josh
earnest explained quote you didn't need
a security clearance to figure out who
benefited from malicious Russian cyber
activity the president-elect didn't call
it into question he called on Russia to
hack his opponent he called on Russia to
hack Secretary Clinton so he certainly
had a pretty good sense of whose side
the cyber activity was coming down on
the last several weeks of the election
were focused on a discussion of emails
that had been hacked and leaked by the
Russians these were emails from the DNC
and John Podesta not from the RNC and
Steven Bannon it was the president-elect
over the course of the campaign
indicated he thought President Putin was
a strong leader the president selects
team his campaign did not make any
effort to obscure this unquote now as I
explained yesterday Hillary didn't lose
because of Vladimir Putin she lost
because she was an awful terrible
horrible candidate that no one likes and
wishes would go away and because Barack
Obama has devastated his party at every
single level of government but Obama has
to find an excuse aside from his own
arrogance and Hillary zoning competence
for the destruction of his legacy and
Putin is as good an excuse as any but
that's not the only excuse Obama has
trotted out he's trotted out fake news
pretending that a bunch of rubes reading
false headlines on Facebook elevated
Trump to the presidency if only they'd
paid attention to the real fake news
distributed by the White House and
members of the mainstream media all
would have been well and of course Obama
thinks the legacy of racism is
responsible for the backlash against his
presidency he was appearing with the
execrable Trevor Noah and he explained
quote we have by no means overcome
legacies of slavery and Jim Crow and
colonialism and racism Obama continued
by stating he had handled the issue of
race just beautifully I mean ignore the
race riots and the DOJ targeting police
departments and Obama making stupid
comments about black people being shot
by the cops but he's genius and not
everybody had appreciated that he said
quote I don't think but trying to appeal
to the better angels of our nature as
Lincoln put it is somehow compromised
there are many reasons why Hillary
Clinton lost but Putin fake news and
racism aren't among them Barack Obama
most definitely is I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
alrighty so here we are we have a lot to
get to today but first we have to say
hello to our friends over at Birch gold
if you are interested in purchasing gold
if you're interested in purchasing
precious metals removing your 401k or
your your IRA into gold without the tax
consequences you need to talk to my
friends at Birch gold you can visit them
at Birch gold calm / been a plus rating
from the better business bureau if
you're concerned about where the economy
is going if you're concerned about
uncertainty then it is imperative that
you go and check out birch cool calm /
Ben right now they have a 16-page freak
it that gives you all the information
you need to know about investing in
precious metals and if you have
questions ask all your questions and
then put part of your portfolio into
precious metals not all of it but some
of it should be in precious metals as a
hedge against inflation and uncertainty
in the markets and Birch gold those are
the people that you want to talk to when
you're ready to invest Birch gold calm /
Ben ok so tons to get to you today here
on ben shapiro first of all it is
imperative to note that Donald Trump
made a major announcement today a really
major announcement today from Trump
Tower and he met with someone just is an
amazing story this is this is you know
this is clip I think this clip 3 here
this is he met with somebody who may be
a member of his cabinet may not be a
member of his cabinet but really an
important meeting here's footage from
Trump Tower this morning
just friends his friends and it's a good
man doing well long times we've been
friends for a long time life good
mascara
want to do it later
it's gotten a buzz by the way for people
who are watching or listening to this
later I have no common burger me the
left side I just wanted to take a
picture right now and then know what
this was supposed to be but it was weird
so Kanye West shows up he wasn't the
only one to show up by the way
apparently Ray Lewis showed up also
wearing his white suit Ray Lewis line
back from Baltimore Ravens he was
wearing his white suit which had Secret
Service deeply concerned because last
time Ray Lewis wore white suit somebody
got stabbed he burned that white so to
suit so this is a different boy suit he
was a trump tower also i'm not sure what
the purpose of all this is I will say
that I'm not saying that Kanye is a gold
digger all I'm saying is that he's not
meeting with any broke okay so that
that's just that's just the point here
so it's a as somebody who mocked
president obama incessantly for meeting
with celebrities i have to mock Donald
Trump for doing exactly the same thing
we have now entered the realm of the
surreal Kanye West at Trump Tower with
with Donald Trump of course that's not
the major news of the day Kanye and
Trump have a warm relationship they have
for a while if you recall Donald Trump
and that there's gonna be running theme
Donald Trump tends to treat people who
praised him and bow before him as as
friends and wonderful sweet political
lovers Kanye West had praised Trump
before here's here's video Kanye West
braising Trump just to put the audacity
to put Anna Wintour right next to Donald
Trump I mean like I put ray j in here
bro like
this is Fame bro like I'm gonna let you
finish but I have no idea what you're
talking about and then their trump
praised Kanye of course because Kanye's
a fan of Trump Kanye West you know what
I'll never say bad about him you know
why cuz he loves Trump he loves Trump he
goes around saying Trump is my all-time
hero he says it to everybody so Kanye
West I love him now maybe in a few years
after run against him i don't know so
i'll take that back but you know what
he's been so nice to me i I sort of you
people have sort of scene because I've
been a counter-puncher I only hit people
when they hit me only and Kanye West has
been so great I would never say bad
about him because he says such nice
things about me Kanye West your new
secretary of doing dope bleep that they
he's going to be doing some real dough
bleep over at the White House it is
amazing speaking of people who he'll
never say bad about because they say
nice about him Vladimir Putin apparently
he's got nothing bad to say about that
so Donald Trump has rolled out his new
secretary of state nominee the person
who's picked its Exxon CEO Rex Tillerson
and he was so excited about about making
America great again that he actually in
his announcement he actually played the
national anthem it was really exciting
[Music]
on that's not fair okay that's not fair
that's not right by the way it is a guy
I will say this about the Russian
national anthem it's pretty spectacular
this was the original USSR national
anthem actually originally was the
Internationale then it became this one
which is a great national anthem and
then they moved away from it they used
one that was written by a guy named
Glinka very famous classical composer
and then Putin because he's actually a
Soviet KGB guy reimpose the USSR
national anthem but in any case here's
what we know about mr. Tillerson who is
the who's the new Secretary of State
pick well we know that he does like
Vladimir Putin he and Putin are on very
friendly terms here just a few pictures
from their honeymoon here's them
together you know just enjoying each
other's company and there they are
looking longingly into one another's
eyes at an exxon mobil event and here's
them just shaking hands and then here is
when Vladimir Putin gave it Rex
Tillerson engagement ring it's actually
just just a metal the order of
friendship now here's what I would like
to say about about tillerson and Putin
the issue here is not tillerson okay
Tillerson was the head of ExxonMobil
ExxonMobil had business relationships in
Russia that's not you know super
shocking ExxonMobil has business
relationships with a lot of terrible
people in 2011 they signed this very
lucrative contract with Vladimir Putin
and then that contract was killed by the
sanctions imposed by the Obama
administration so tillerson has been
very much against the Russian sanctions
because it destroyed this contract that
Exxon had with Vladimir Putin important
to mention here Vladimir Putin is
legitimately one of the worst people on
planet earth okay he's not somebody that
you want to play with there are three
separate presidents who have now tried
to play footsie with Vladimir Putin and
three separate times Vladimir Putin has
humiliated them by doing exactly what he
wants to do running roughshod into other
countries murdering people in Syria
right now people backed by Vladimir
Putin are murder and women and children
there are women who are committing
suicide rather than be raped by Assad's
forces in aleppo it is Putin who's
standing behind assad forces Putin's a
very bad guy and all these people who
think that you're going to be able to
use Vladimir Putin to your advantage no
bladimir Putin is not used by you and
he's not used by Trump Vladimir Putin is
a user he is not the easy case I'm gonna
be Trump using Vladimir Putin to do his
bidding it's going to be Vladimir Putin
doing what he wants to do and from
standing to the side letting him do it
so
I'm not going to blame you know Rex
Tillerson for being the head of Exxon
I'm sure that a lot of heads of Exxon
would have done exactly what Rex
Tillerson said I don't think it's
uniquely bad human being I don't think
is uniquely bad politician or anything I
do think that Donald Trump's decision to
to massage Vladimir Putin's ass for
literally the entirety of this election
cycle and now continuing forward that
should be troublesome to a lot of
Republicans like it should be
troublesome that the Russians are so
excited about this there's a Russian MP
who tweeted this out earlier today his
name is Alexei Pushkov and he is a
fellow who has said in the past that the
the navy yard shooting if you remember
in washington DC a few years back the
navy yard shooting the navy yard
shooting he said that that was american
exceptionalism very anti-american guy he
celebrated the the appointment of tell
erson because he's considered a Russian
ally and so you know this is not good
news for people who are hoping that
Trump was going to moderate or not be
Trump Trump was only consistent about a
couple of things during this campaign
one is he doesn't really like trade and
one is he really does like Vladimir
Putin you remember we played a montage
yesterday of him talking about Putin all
the way up to and including denying the
Putin had ever told journalists which is
not true him denying that Putin was a
human rights violator America's violated
human rights too he's been very very
much in Putin's corner obviously his
former campaign manager Paul Manafort
was so much in Putin's quarter that he
was being investigated by the FBI so
this has not changed it's disquieting
this isn't about tillerson it's about
Trump and and it is not a good indicator
again Vladimir Putin is one of the
world's worst human beings well Admiral
Putin murders dissidents Vladimir Putin
runs a petrol oligarchy where he and his
friend zone all the assets in Russia
Vladimir Putin has now built a personal
fortune somewhere in the neighborhood of
forty billion dollars 40 billion dollars
he just built himself a giant 1 billion
dollar mansion he imprisons dissidents
he is shut down freedom of the press
Vladimir Putin is a is in an absolute
kleptocratic tater and he is and he's an
evil evil fellow who's engaged in some
of the worst Human Rights atrocities
that we've seen in the past 10-15 years
he also has obviously invaded
surrounding countries Crimea he invaded
Georgia when George W Bush was president
now a lot of people are pointing out the
condi rice and Bob gates and some kind
of heavyweights of endorsed tillerson
two things to note about
Bob gates and condi rice run a
consulting firm for which killer ssin is
a client Dick Cheney has praised
Tillerson he is not somebody who
presumably has business interests
directly with tillerson James Baker who
actually works with Putin very closely
has praised tillerson again i'm not
saying tiller sins a bad guy I'm not
even saying the tillerson is you know
anti-american or has Putin's best
interests at heart or any of that what I
am saying is the only thing that Trump
knows about him the only thing anybody
knows about him on foreign policies that
he's super tight with Putin and that was
the reason why Trump picked him in the
first place and that is disturbing that
should be disturbing to anybody who
cares about this sort of stuff again
Vladimir Putin is a very very bad guy
and it is disturbing to me how many
Republicans are willing to embrace this
just because it's from doing it you can
call hypocrisy on Democrats and I'm
happy to do it we'll talk about that in
a second Democrats are hypocrites about
Russia but so are Republicans I mean you
know you really don't get to claim that
you are anti-putin if you're then going
to sit around claiming that Donald Trump
is doing wonders by siding with Putin
we'll get to that in just a second by
the way tillerson also has a pretty
checkered record with regard to things
like global warming which does make a
difference it was John Kerry negotiating
global warming treaties while he was
Secretary of State under under Barack
Obama tillerson embraces the notion that
that man is creating global warming he's
actually even embraced a carbon tax
here's what he had to say about it
recently clearly there's going to be an
impact so I'm not not disputing that
increasing co2 emissions and atmosphere
is going to have an impact it will have
a warming impact the how large it is is
what is very hard for anyone to predict
and depend on how large it is then
projects how dire the consequences are
he's come out in favor of a carbon tax
as well a cap-and-trade which is the Al
Gore program so all these people who are
very excited about Scott Pruett
understand that the secretary of state
does not agree with Scott Pruett on
global warming or it's possible to read
it as he was saying what he had to say
cos he was head of ExxonMobil but we
don't know the answer to that right now
so we'll leave that one on the table
okay so normally if a major head of an
oil company whose main foreign policy
experience was being best friends with
Vladimir Putin was nominated you would
think Republicans might oppose this well
you'd be wrong here's Paul Ryan's
response Paul Ryan said congratulations
to Rex Tillerson a proven leader and
person of enormous accomplishment Mitch
McConnell also praised Rex Tillerson he
said I look forward to supporting his
nomination so forget about you know
actually having hearings in determining
what his views are he looks forward to
supporting his nomination and it is
fascinating to watch as people do this
now i think the motivation here is that
there are a lot of people in Congress
Republicans in Congress who think that
if they are really really nice to Donald
Trump if they give him everything that
he wants he'll be nice to them so I
don't know what Paul Ryan is I think
Paul Ryan is actually delusional at this
point about Trump I think he thinks if
I'm really nice to Donald Trump if I
give him all the things he wants then
Donald Trump will do entitlement reform
hahaha as Paul Ryan learned nothing not
going to happen Donald Trump is going to
do what Donald Trump wants to do and
Newt Gingrich who's just become the
pseudo intellectual shill for trumpism
he did a lecture at Heritage Foundation
today in way that was called the
principles of trumpism which is a new
one I wasn't aware there were any
principles of trumpism other than what
Donald Trump feels like this morning the
first principle of trumpism according to
newt gingrich is praise Trump to the
skies and then up your speakers fee
based on that but he gave a speech about
principles of trumpism and he called
Trump a grizzly bear who basically if he
got his attention is going to claw off
your face you compared him to the
grizzly bear from the revenant I guess
that will we have yet to see whether
whether there was some sort of rape that
went on with Leonardo DiCaprio a bear
rape that went on with Leonardo DiCaprio
when DiCaprio visited Trump Tower but
the idea that you're going to control
Trump is just this is such an illusion
and it's something that I think
McConnell and Ryan are both engaging in
this idea that if you're nice to him
he's going to give you what you want not
unless he already has a predilection
toward you and this is the caveat you
know he said earlier about Kanye West
Kanye's been nice to me so I'll be nice
to him right because it doesn't lose
anything Putin is nice to him so he's
nice to Putin right because Donald Trump
is the kind of guy who is who's
attracted to power and thinks power is
attractive and so he likes the fact that
Putin is throwing like boom so of course
he's going to be okay with Vladimir
Putin but that doesn't mean he's going
to start green-lighting entitlement
reform which he's opposed the entire way
through he thinks entitlement reform is
a political disaster he's not going to
back Paul Ryan's play on that
Republicans keep going along to get
along that's going to have consequences
because all you're doing is convincing
people the Trump is right where he's
wrong and then he's just going to screw
you anyway right as Mitt Romney
found out Mitt Romney put out a
statement and he's not Secretary of
State obviously and Mitt Romney put out
this this little statement about about
not being Secretary of State here's what
it said this is 11 he's he it says quote
it was an honor to have been considered
for secretary of state of our great
country my discussions with presidents
like Trump have been both enjoyable and
enlightening I have very high hopes that
the new administration will lead the
nation to greater strength prosperity
and peace I also hope that this
administration will do all of those
things also this was shortly after King
Joffrey Baratheon Trump the first
beheaded Ned Stark after after I listen
I said it at the time right we actually
played a clip from game of thrones of
this happening Romney's head now
decorates the the gates at King's
Landing so too bad for him meanwhile
Ryan's Priebus is making overtures
toward trumpism on this and and his
defenses of Trump and Russia are not
particularly good here's here's what he
had to say well what he said was that
the sanctions were ineffective but the
reason they were ineffective was that
they weren't being enforced and so his
point was unless you're going to enforce
these sanctions they're not effective
and people are looking at the the first
part of that statement and not just like
look I know where Rex Tillerson is on
this he believes that sanctions and the
threat of sanctions are an important
part of international strategy and
diplomacy and so he's not against
sanctions I just want to assure you of
that but what he is against is setting
up sanctions that aren't in fort ok so
that's not true Tillerson as he has said
he was against the Russian sanctions it
wasn't about the enforceability we'll
see if they remove sanctions from Russia
that would be pretty amazing if they
remove sections from Russia meanwhile
Priebus continued by saying it's not
it's not bad to have good relationship
with Vladimir Putin this this language
is exactly the language the Barack Obama
used about Cuba it's the same language
that Barack Obama has used about Putin
in the past hows about have good
relationships with the enemies you only
make peace with your elements here is
brian's previs the the chauffeur for the
trump administration but the truth is is
that having relationships with people is
not a bad thing i don't know how we got
to the place where having an actual
functional relationship with someone who
might not be a person that we first
think of to have that relationship with
is suddenly a
bad thing I mean we have a lot of
problems in this world and we're not
going to solve those problems by making
believe that people don't exist and so
America first that's what president
elect Trump lives by every day that's
what's in his head everyday Americans
first America first we're going to be
tough across the world and president
like Trump and Rex Tillerson and in vice
president-elect pants are going to take
every day with that mindset in place
okay so I love that he doesn't have any
real defense for this so instead he just
starts shouting America first mega mega
mega America first not paying attention
not listening by mega okay yes I
understand mega okay this doesn't have
anything to with America first the
question is how close are you supposed
to be to one of the worst dictators on
planet earth Marco Rubio gets this right
here's Rubio statement about Tillerson
he says quote while rex tillerson is a
respected businessman i have serious
concerns about his nomination the next
Secretary of State must be someone who
have used the world with moral clarity
is free of potential conflicts of
interest has a clear sense of America's
interests and will be a forceful
advocate for America's foreign policy
goals to the president within the
administration and on the world stage I
look forward to learning more about his
records and his views I will do my part
to ensure he receives a full and fair
hearing etc etc that's basically the
tactic that a lot of these people should
be taking but that is not the tactic
that a lot of people are taking instead
everybody is just ignoring serious
questions that ought to be asked about
Russia and Vladimir Putin and what he's
doing in favor of sort of partisan
breakdowns and we'll get to more of that
in just a bit plus Democrats
overreacting because they can't help
themselves it is amazing that just every
land mine they have to jump on with both
feet every rake must be stepped on all
of them every rake in creation will get
to all of that but you have to subscribe
a daily wire to see it you can listen of
course later on iTunes or SoundCloud but
daily wire.com to subscribe eight bucks
a month annual subscription gets you a
free copy of my book true allegiance
signed by me and we have lots of goodies
coming at the daily wire at the daily
whiter store which is going to be
opening up pretty soon discounts are
available for subscribers of course plus
we're going to deconstruct the culture a
little bit later which is going to be a
lot of fun I'm gonna check it out at
daily wire calm we are the largest
conservative podcast on the internets
[Music]